I’M JESSE WATTERS.
PRESIDENT RELEASE A VIDEO FROM
WALTER REED MEDICAL CENTER
UPDATING THE COUNTRY ON HIS
CONDITION.
>> I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY,
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES AT THE
WALTER REED MEDICAL CENTER.
I CAME HERE, WASN’T FEELING SO
WELL.
I FEEL MUCH BETTER NOW.
WE ARE WORKING HARD TO GET ME
ALL THE WAY BACK.
I HAVE TO BE BACK BECAUSE WE
STILL NEED TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
I HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB OF THAT.
BUT WE HAVE STEPS TO GO, WE HAVE
TO FINISH THAT JOB.
I THINK I WILL BE BACK SOON.
I LOOK FORWARD TO FINISHING UP
THE CAMPAIGN WITH THE KINDS OF
NUMBERS WE HAVE BEEN DOING.
WE HAVE BEEN SO PROUD OF IT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
IT HAPPENED TO MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD.
NOT JUST IN THE U.S.
I’M FIGHTING FOR THEM ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
WE ARE GOING TO BEAT THIS
CORONAVIRUS OR WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT AND WE’LL BITE
SOUNDLY.
SO MANY THINGS HAPPENED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE THERAPEUTICS
I’M TAKING.
AND OTHERS ARE COMING OUT SOON
THAT FRANKLY THEY ARE MIRACLES.
PEOPLE CRITICIZE ME WHEN I SAY
THAT.
BUT WE HAVE THINGS HAPPENING
THAT LOOK LIKE THEY ARE MIRACLES
COMING DOWN FROM GOD.
I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT I’M
STARTING TO FEEL GOOD.
YOU DON’T KNOW OVER THE NEXT
PERIOD OF A FEW DAYS, I GUESS
THAT’S THE REAL TEST.
SO WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS.
I JUST WANT TO BE SO THANKFUL
FOR ALL OF THE SUPPORTIVE SEEN,
WHETHER IT’S ON TELEVISION OR
READING ABOUT IT.
MOST OF ALL I APPRECIATE WHAT’S
BEEN SAID ABOUT IT AMERICAN
PEOPLE, BY ALMOST A BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS OF AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT’S A BEAUTIFUL THING TO SEE,
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
AND I WON’T FORGET IT.
I PROMISE YOU THAT.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE LEADERS
OF THE WORLD FOR THEIR
CONDOLENCES AND THEY KNOW WHAT
WE ARE GOING THROUGH.
THEY KNOW AS YOUR LEADER WHAT I
HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
BUT I HAD NO CHOICE BECAUSE I
JUST DIDN’T WANT TO STAY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
STAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE, LOCK
YOURSELF IN, DON’T EVER LEAVE.
DON’T GO TO THE OVAL OFFICE.
STAY UPSTAIRS AND ENJOY IT.
DON’T SEE PEOPLE, DON’T TALK TO
PEOPLE AND BE DONE WITH IT.
AND I CAN’T DO THAT.
I HAD TO BE OUT FRONT.
THIS IS AMERICA.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
THIS IS THE MOST POWERFUL
COUNTRY UNTIL WORLD.
I CAN’T BE LOCKED UPSTAIRS IN A
ROOM AND BE TOTALLY SAFE AND SAY
WHATEVER HAPPENS, HAPPENS.
I CAN’T DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO CONFRONT PROBLEMS.
AS A LEADER YOU HAVE TO CON
FRONT PROBLEMS.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A GREAT
LEADER THAT WOULD HAVE DONE
THAT.
I AM DOING WELL.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY.
OUR FIRST LADY IS DOING VERY
WELL.
MELANIA ASKED ME TO SAY
SOMETHING AS TO THE RESPECT SHE
HAS FOR OUR COUNTRY, THE LOVE
SHE HAS FOR OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE BOTH DOING WELL.
MELANIA IS REALLY HANDLING IT
VERY NICELY.
AS YOU PROBABLY READ, SHE IS
SLIGHTLY YOUNGER THAN ME, JUST A
TINY BIT.
AND WE NOTE DISEASE.
WE KNOW THE SITUATION WITH AGE
VERSUS YOUNGER PEOPLE.
AND MELANIA IS HANDLING IT
STATISTICALLY LIKE IT’S SUPPOSED
TO BE HANDLED.
AND THAT MAKES ME VERY HAPPY AND
MAKES THE COUNTRY VERY HAPPY.
BUT I’M ALSO DOING WELL, AND I
THINK WE’LL HAVE A VERY GOOD
RESULT.
OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS WE’LL
PROBABLY KNOW FOR SURE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY OUT THERE, EVERYBODY.
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SPECIFICALLY THE OUTPOURING OF